kontrollen an deutschen grenzen an den
übergang von tschechien und tirol bilden
sich erste staus größere probleme werden
noch befürchtet freispruch für donald
trump nachdem impeachment verfahren
bringen sich die beteiligten neu in
stellung
auch der ex präsident selbst nächste
silber sensation bei der ski-wm andreas
sander überrascht bei der abfahrt und
schrammt nur hauchdünn an gold vorbei
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster herzlich willkommen bei
den 19 uhr nachrichten am sonntag für
den sport ist heute wieder norbert könig
an meiner seite nahmen seit heute nacht
werden einreisende aus tschechien und
tirol an der grenze kontrolliert und
nicht wenige wieder zurückgeschickt die
virus mutanten die jenseits für hohe
ansteckungsraten sorgen will man so
draußen halten
doch brüssel kritisiert die aktion die
wohl zu sehr an den alleingang der
länder im letzten corona frühjahr
erinnert und die heimische industrie
fürchtet um ihre umsätze utah sonne wald
und petra neubauer auto für auto wird
seit mitternacht an der deutsch
tschechischen grenze wie hier bei
waldsassen kontrolliert wer keine
einreise berechtigung hat muss umkehren
es ist der versuch die britische virus
variante die gerade in tschechien so
wütet einzudämmen sicherheit und schutz
steht in diesen zeiten an oberster
stelle deswegen jetzt die stationären
grenzkontrollen deswegen auch die
zurückweisungen die aus meiner hinsicht
notwendig sind dies ist ein strenges
einreise geschieht ja aber es ist
notwendig nur einige wenige ausnahmen
von den strengen regeln soll es geben
etwa für pendler aus medizinischen oder
anderen systemrelevanten bereiche
obliegt den landratsämtern innerhalb
dieser beiden tage montag und dienstag
nun dann überall die entscheidungen zu
treffen festzulegen welche betriebe hier
überall betroffen sind systemrelevant
sind um einreisen zu dürfen braucht man
auf alle fälle einen negativen corona
test der muss spätestens alle 48 stunden
erneuert werden die scharfen
grenzkontrollen stoßen hier teils auf
unverständnis
48 stunden testen müssen und negativen
test haben müssen ja also verstehe wie
grenz maßnahmen nicht in sachsen macht
sich andrea schöpp versorgen um ihre
baumwoll weberei die gilt nicht als
systemrelevant zwölf beschäftigte
pendeln täglich aus tschechien hierher
was wenn diese nun fehlen das bedeutet
für uns umsatzeinbrüche die wir uns
einfach nicht leisten können wir haben
verträge im
die bücher voll am grenzübergang
breitenau in sachsen haben sich durch
die kontrollen schon heute lange
rückstaus gebildet eine situation die
sich mit beginn des berufsverkehrs
morgen weiter verschärfen dürfte und
genau da am grenzübergang breitenau an
der a 17 richtung prag schaut sich
steffen moritz für uns die lage an
steffi wie sieht es denn aus zurzeit ja
eigentlich schon den ganzen tag über
schon seit heute morgen muss man hier
doch mit erheblichen wartezeiten rechnen
fahrer mit denen wir uns unterhalten
haben als jene uns was von drei bis vier
stunden wartezeit und diejenigen müssen
sich dann hier in solche sogenannten
warte straßen einordnen und da geht es
dann auch wirklich nur sehr sehr langsam
voran
vielleicht sieht man es auch hinter mir
den berg hoch staut es sich zurück wie
uns die bundespolizei sagte etwa fünf
bis sechs kilometer geht der stau zurück
nach tschechien
ja und diejenigen die hier in der in der
warthestraße stehen
das sind am wenigsten reisende aus
tschechien denn die haben sich trotz der
kurzfristigkeit über die neuen grenz
modalitäten wohl informiert die die hier
stehen sind vor allem reisende die
ausländer kommen die hinter tschechien
liegen also moldawien rumänien bulgarien
ungarn und die waren heute sehr erstaunt
als sie hier an der grenze ankamen und
erfuhren dass ab sofort ein aktueller
täglicher corona test erforderlich ist
und sicher überhaupt die einreise
modalitäten geändert haben
aber auch da im gespräch haben wir sehr
viel verständnis für die neuen maßnahmen
gespürt was auch daran liegt dass die
bundespolizei ihnen vor ort hier einen
neuen corona test ermöglicht und sie
demzufolge nicht gleich wieder alle
zurückschicken muss wenn sie denn die
ausnahmeregeln erfüllen etwa drei
stunden beginnt dann hier der
transitverkehr wieder zu rollen da
rechnet man noch mal mit einer
deutlichen verschärfung der situation
und die pendler kommen morgen früh da
noch dazu die situation an der
südöstlichen grenze deutschlands vielen
dank der 4 steffen moritz
sachsens ministerpräsident kretschmann
cdu schließt osterurlaub in deutschland
aus zu große mobilität durchreise
verkehr und tourismus bereits im april
sei gift sagte er der bild am sonntag
wir werden alles zerstören was wir seit
mitte dezember
erreicht haben in sachsen kündigte
kretschmann blieben gaststätten und
hotels auch über ostern geschlossen der
korona incidents wert in deutschland
geht laut robert koch institut weiter
zurück durchschnittlich liegt er jetzt
bei 57
in absoluten zahlen wurden 6114 neue
ansteckungen in 24 stunden erfasst rund
2500 weniger als vergangenen sonntag 218
menschen starben in verbindung mit 19
auch im zweiten anlauf sind die
demokraten gescheitert dass im pitch
bend gegen den ehemaligen us präsidenten
endet mit einem freispruch
die demokraten sprechen von einer
schande trump feiert das als sieg einige
republikaner innen machen trump zwar
verantwortlich für die erstürmung des
kapitals halten das verfahren aber für
verfassungswidrig oder wollen schlicht
nicht mit ihm brechen
kampala die sonntagszeitungen verkünden
es in großen schlagzeilen der senat
spricht donald trump wieder frei 57 der
senatorinnen und senatoren stimmten für
schuldig 43 für nicht schuldig keine
zwei drittel mehrheit die klage donald
trump habe zum aufruhr angestiftet ist
abgeschmettert
der freigesprochene bedankt sie
schriftlich verbreitet aber auch wieder
den vorwurf von der größten hexenjagd in
der geschichte unseres landes und an
seiner anhänger gerichtet unsere
historische patriotische unschöne
bewegung um amerika wieder großartig zu
machen hat erst begonnen
sieben republikaner stimmten gegen trump
17 hätten es für eine verurteilung sein
müssen
der freispruch entschuldigt jedoch auch
in den augen mancher republikaner
keinesfalls die gewalt am kapitol
präsident trump ist praktisch und
moralisch verantwortlich wir haben keine
macht einen ehemaligen amtsinhaber zu
verurteilen und zu disqualifizieren der
jetzt ein privater bürger ist
opportunismus siegt über die moral so
bewerten die demokraten das verhalten
der republikaner
sie haben angst macht zu verlieren ihre
sitze zu verlieren
sie haben sich ausgerechnet das macht er
halt die nato zu bleiben wichtiger war
als ihr land für den neuen mann im
weißen haus präsident joe biden bleibt
das wesentliche der anschuldigungen
unbestritten das ende eines traurigen
kapitels schreibt er
während ex-präsident trump klar macht
dass man mit ihm weiter rechnen muss
nach russland haben heute anhängerinnen
des verurteilten kremlkritikers alexei
navalny protestiert in moskau erinnerten
hunderte frauen mit einer menschenkette
auch an die anderen inhaftierten bei den
demonstrationen für eine weile hatten
sicherheitskräfte insgesamt mehr als
11.000 menschen festgenommen und noch
eine aktion heute landesweit richteten
wallis anhänger aus solidarität
taschenlampen in den himmel
bei dem schweren erdbeben vor der
ostküste japans sind mehr als 110
menschen verletzt worden
die erschütterungen der stärke 7,3 löste
auch erdrutsche aus
viele gebäude entlang der küste wurden
beschädigt hunderttausende haushalte
waren zeitweise ohne strom
das epizentrum lag wieder vor fukushima
dort hatte vor zehn jahren ein
verheerendes beben einen tsunami und
einen gau im atomkraftwerk ausgelöst
ja und damit zum wintersport mit der
nächsten großen überraschung in cortina
d'ampezzo und norbert ja das ist nach
dem bisherigen weltcup ergebnis ein
wirklich unglaublich um eine
hundertstelsekunde verpasst heute
andreas sander den weltmeistertitel im
vierten speed-rennen ist das die dritte
silbermedaille für deutschland
da staunt der protagonist selbst andreas
sander gelingt ein nahezu perfekter lauf
umgerechnet fehlen dem 31 jährigen aus
ennepetal auf der ziellinie ganze 27
zentimeter auf den titel doch die freude
überwiegt
einen großen dank und so richtig
begreifen kann ich irgendwie nicht
spektakulär bei tempo 120 die stunt
einlagen des franzosen max mühsam und
romed baumann heute vierzehnter kraft in
die ziel bande die folge schnittwunden
im gesicht weltmeister wird der
österreicher vincent kriechmayr platz
drei belegt rechts im bild wertvoll aus
der schweiz
wer im titel nummer elf francesco
friedrich ist das maß der dinge im
bobsport nach dem sieg im zweierbob
schafft friedrich in altenberg auch den
triumph im großen schlitten bronze holt
johannes lochner bereits zum vierten mal
schafft rekordweltmeister friedrich den
doppelerfolg genau wie 2018 bei den
olympischen spielen
franziska preuß wird fünfte im
verfolgungs rennen der biathlon-wm in
pokljuka direkt vor teamkollegin vanessa
hinzu ihr drittes gold holte die
norwegerin thierry lacoste und alexander
zverev hat bei den australian open in
melbourne das viertelfinale erreicht der
weltranglisten-siebte schlägt den serben
dusan lajovic souverän in drei sätzen
sein fünfzigste erfolgreiches match bei
einem grand-slam-turnier
der nächste gegner hat schon 300 auf dem
konto novak djokovic nummer eins der
welt und eintracht frankfurt steht nach
dem zehnten saisonsieg in der fußball
bundesliga 2 0 gegen in essen ist sie
können vorläufig auf platz drei danke
norbert und wir haben noch die
wetteraussichten zum start in die neue
woche am vormittag im westen schnee und
eisregen der bis zum nachmittag etwa die
elbe reicht dabei besteht große
glatteisgefahr sonst noch meist
freundlich bei minus vier bis plus acht
grad so viel von uns für den moment
danke für ihr interesse
mehr gibt es im heute journal mit
marietta slomka um 21 uhr 45 und morgen
freut sich christian sievers hier auf
sie wir sagen adieu